>> Sean: RIGHT NOW HOLLYWOOD
IS CONTINUING TO RAMP UP THERE
DAILY HATRED CAMPAIGN.
ROBERT DE NIRO TOTALLY UNHINGED,
ANOTHER VULGAR RANT AND OF
COURSE THIS BEHAVIOR HAS BEEN
GOING ON NOW FOR TWO YEARS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YES, I'M ANGRY.
YES, I AM OUTRAGED.
YES, I HAVE THOUGHT AN AWFUL LOT
ABOUT BLOWING UP THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME AN
ACTOR ASSASSINATED A PRESIDENT?
AND I WANT TO CLARIFY, I'M NOT
AN ACTOR.
I LIVE FOR A LIVING.
[LAUGHTER]
HOWEVER, IT'S BEEN A WHILE.
AND MAYBE IT'S TIME.
>> TODAY THE WORLD IS SUFFERING
FROM THE REAL DONALD TRUMP.
COME ON, LET'S GO, WHAT ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT?
LET'S CLAP FOR THAT.
THIS [BLEEP] IDIOT IS THE
PRESIDENT.
THE GUY IS A [BLEEP] FOOL, COME
ON.
OUR GOVERNMENT TODAY WITH THE
PROMPTING OF OUR BABY IN CHIEF
HAS [BLEEP] AS I CALL HIM.
>> Sean: AND GET THE PRESIDENT
HAS SHATTERED ONE ECONOMIC
RECORD RIGHT AFTER ANOTHER, FROM
UNEMPLOYMENT RIGHT DOWN THE
LINE.
PIERS MORGAN IS WITH US, AND HE
BY THE WAY IS IN THE U.S.
HOSTING DAILY MAIL TV EARLY
TODAY AND TOMORROW.
YOU ARE SHOW IS A MASSIVE HIT.
HER ONLY MISTAKE IN TV IN THE
U.S. IS LECTURING AMERICANS
ABOUT GUNS WHICH I DON'T WANT TO
TALK ABOUT.
>> WE COULD GO A LONG TIME ON
GUNS, BUT LET'S NOT DO IT
TONIGHT.
AND I'M BLAMING THIS ON A LARGE
RIBEYE STEAK I HAD EARLIER THIS
EVENING.
UNFORTUNATELY, YOU'RE SURE IT
WAS MUCH TOO BIG FOR ME.
>> PROBABLY, IT'S BIG BECAUSE I
DO MIXED MARTIAL ARTS 90 MINUTES
PER DAY.
>> OF COURSE.
WELCOME BACK, I KNOW YOU HAVE A
HUGE SHOW AND HUGE SUCCESS.
I LOVE YOUR ICONOCLASTIC NATURE
ON TWITTER ALTHOUGH I GOT BORED
WITH IT, I DID IT FOR A WHILE.
IF I HAD ONE PIECE OF ADVICE
FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP, IT WOULD
BE THIS.
HE CAN COMMUNICATE WITH SO MANY
PEOPLE ON TWITTER, HE DOESN'T
EVEN NEED THE MEDIA TO DO THAT.
>> HONESTLY IF YOU TOOK AWAY THE
TWEETS AND THE RHETORIC FROM
DONALD TRUMP'S DETRACTORS AND
FOCUSED ON WHAT HE DID AS
PRESIDENT, HE WOULD BE NOWHERE
NEAR TO SCARY AS TO THEM AS HE
IS.
FOR TWO YEARS NOW, HE'S HAD MOST
OF THE MAJOR LIBERAL CELEBRITIES
OF THE WORLD BASICALLY SCREAMING
IN A MASSIVE GIGANTIC HISSY FIT
THAT THEIR CHOICE
HILLARY CLINTON DID NOT WIN THE
ELECTION.
THEY CANNOT ABIDE THE FACT THAT
SOMEBODY LIKE TRUMP, A CELEBRITY
ACTUALLY LIKE THEM SOMEHOW WITH
LITTLE EXPERIENCE CAME THROUGH
AND WON THE WHITE HOUSE.
IT REMINDS ME A BIT OF THE
DEBATE IN BRITAIN, WHICH IS
EXACTLY THE SAME THING.
WHERE EVERYONE THAT BELIEVES IN
BREXIT MUST BE RACIST AND
SEXIST.
FRANKLY PEOPLE SHOULD BE
ARRESTED FOR SAYING SOME OF THE
STUFF THEY HAVE BEEN SAYING.
THEY'VE MADE DIRECT BOMB THREATS
TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
AND I'VE MADE THIS POINT TO
THEM.
YOU CAN SCREAM AS MUCH AS YOU
HAVE LIKED.
YOU CAN BE AS ABUSIVE ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP AS YOU WANT TO BE.
YOU CAN CALL HIM ALL THE NAMES
YOU WOULD LIKE TO CALL HIM BUT,
CALL HIM DONALD TRUMP, IT WILL
RALLY HIS BASE AND AS WE SAW
WITH HILLARY CLINTON WHEN SHE
PLAYED THE CELEBRITY CARD SO
HARD IN 2016, IT DOESN'T WORK.
TAYLOR SWIFT AND OPRAH WINFREY
RECENTLY IN THE MIDTERMS, BOTH
BACK CANDIDATES THAT LOST, TWO
OF THE BIGGEST STARS IN AMERICA
THAT WITH GOOD FOLLOWINGS.
YOU HAVE TO BE OFFERING
SOMETHING MORE, AND I'M LIKE
YOU.
I FIND IT VOMIT MAKING THAT
THESE STARS TIME AND AGAIN JUST
THINK IT'S COOL AND PRODUCTIVE
TO SCREAM ABUSE AT THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
THERE IS NO RESPECT FOR THE
OFFICE IN NO RESPECT FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE AND FRANKLY NOT MUCH
RESPECT FOR THEIR OWN FANS, MANY
OF WHOM WILL HAVE VOTED FOR
TRUMP.
>> AND THE ECONOMIC SUCCESS,
RECORD UNEMPLOYMENT IN 14
STATES.
ASIAN-AMERICANS, WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE, YOUTH UNEMPLOYMENT,
SHATTERING RECORDS WHICH IS
GREAT FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
MATTER, THAT MAKE I THINK,
AMERICA GREAT.
YOU PICKED UP SOMETHING THAT
VERY FEW PEOPLE DID.
OBAMA LOST 69 BETWEEN THE HOUSE
AND SENATE SEATS IN HIS FIRST
MIDTERM, CLINTON 60, AND
DONALD TRUMP DID SOMETHING THAT
ONLY HAPPENED A HUNDRED TIMES,
PICKED UP SENATE SEATS.
>> I WROTE A COLUMN FOR DAILY
MAIL SAYING TO THE DEMOCRATS,
LOOK.
YOU HAVE TO TRY TO BEAT HIM IN
2020.
YOU CAN SAY LOOK, HE IMPROVED
HIS MAJORITY IN THE SENATE AND
WON A LOT OF OTHER RACES THAT
OTHER PEOPLE DIDN'T THINK HE
WOULD WIN.
OBVIOUSLY HE HAD A LOSS, HE LOST
THE HOUSE.
BUT I IF I WAS A DEMOCRAT, I
WOULD LOOK AT THOSE RESULTS IN
TOTALITY AND SAY, HOW ARE WE
GOING TO BEAT THIS GUY?
HE'S A REALLY AN CAMPAIGNER,
DOING RALLY AFTER RALLY, HIS
BASE LOOKS ROCK-SOLID AND HE HAS
ALL THE USUAL SUSPECTS SCREAMING
AT HIM AND IS TELLING HIM HE'S
AN IDIOT AND YET HE IS AND
ENCUMBERED WHITE HOUSE
PRESIDENT.
AND YET THE ODDS ARE SOMETHING
LIKE 75% AS ALL THE CANDIDATES
TO RUN AGAIN -- DONALD TRUMP HAS
A VERY, VERY GOOD CHANCE I WOULD
SAY OF WINNING THE NEXT
ELECTION.
IF YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT, STOP
SCREAMING AND TRY TO FIND THE
CANDIDATE AND A MESSAGE WHICH
COULD ACTUALLY BEAT HIM BECAUSE
I DON'T SEE THAT EITHER.
>> Sean: YOU ARE GIVING VERY
SMART, SOUND ADVICE AND THEY
WILL NEVER FOLLOW IT.
IN THE NEXT TWO YEARS, WE WILL
CHRONICLE THE INSANITY THAT
CONTINUES.
ALL RIGHT, THE NEXT TIME YOU ARE
IN THE STATES, I WANT YOU TO INV
IN THE STATES, I WANT YOU TO INT
IN THE STATES, I WANT YOU TO INE
IN THE STATES, I WANT YOU TO INY
IN THE STATES, I WANT YOU TO INU
WANT TO COME INTO MY HOUSE TO
SEE MY GUN COLLECTION.
AND, I'M GOING TO TAKE YOU
SHOOTING.
>> I WILL DO THAT BUT I WILL
ALSO CONVINCE YOU THAT SINCE WE
TOOK AWAY ALL THE GUNS IN MY
COUNTRY COME IN BRITAIN, IT WAS